okay ya suckers reptile I was done with
this game
I actually unstyled it last night and I
was like hey like there's at the I'll
say but I can I get it you know check to
the L say it was like very point like I
mean that point it's like it's like 399
and I was like a remembers morning us
craving it like I was just craving more
adventure you know let's get my
Starbucks and I was like why not why not
so how I go yeah I try to talk a lot
more because I think a lot of lazy and
I've been like playing and be like every
so often
ok they're gonna be here Sam how can I
get ready in life
whoa hey just really how it is holy crap
ok honor okay okay I don't think we knew
controller for this I don't like how
it's like choppy like this yes it's like
it jumps the zones wait check this okay
I think I'm not going to use a control
for this I like how there's really just
no that's tell us you like that that's
what I did a hater so kay I just say a
hater and I said like nothing count
gasoline might be some more grass lamb
as well load up oh there's a instruction
no top you may notice that you can't see
here anything in here
how about hater okay let me just connect
this because they left control and
Dustin was sick vibrating I don't know
what that said all right I can't just
hit here for the action you know oops
sorry but rum
even the cops rate the department they
won't find anything all data stored in
the server all informant asked what a
rage while you're at it
amen brother you're going to message ACK
hello jack I hear that data transfer a
hunch perset what did he transfer Oh Oh
what the heck is that
that's disgusting I like the bat is
faster any when I live in here suits
Thanks
order the Advent I wouldn't even have
sup I read a little bit about this and I
heard that it really does not add like
any storage like combat like if you want
a more story it actually makes it more
confusing so I'm kind of going to kind
of fly through the story hello sorry
take that guys could tell out of here
again the music I'm not the biggest fan
of um it's like I like that it's custom
like it's obviously not really reusing
anything except all the the soundtracks
like all the songs how much I am I kind
of just like hate what I just like
drones you know he'll I craft I think
you this is different
crap you turn the music down a little
you
shut up Harry how do you
oh is this is help
fast forward oh my god that seriously
just made this game without an eyes
better the last one was way too long
it wasn't enough to do to give you add
this up to heal a person or not
okay you mess something up
uh hello Jonathan see that just chop
them up just chop them I speak Japanese
hello sir
Oh what the heck I'd say what's down
here just slide out like a spider monkey
hello thank you
thank you current show tour the guardian
out oh so these ones with the curved
backs it looks like they crawl I hope
that can is over there look this guy's
just sitting in the movies enter how
laaser take an underground movie theater
so can I take multiple people I don't
know water so what is like the purpose
of this oh I can't just like I have to
get gasoline okay let's just fly through
this a my dear hello sir
gunpowder our pills not too bad not too
bad like a background now um oh my god
I'm recording so we got four second I'm
most terrified I just like I'm not
recording hey guys I just feel like I'm
wasting my life I don't know I got at
this point where I'm just like if I'm
going to do something I should like um
might as well make something out of it I
don't want to be one with people that
just kind of leach around and don't do
any like - she's up resources like I'd
rather enjoy myself and add to
communities that's why I record thanks
you know Nick Kelly's slime balls
I don't know why I should even use a
medkit
it's like if you die you you kind of
show up like the only a couple feet away
where you died you know okay I got the
gasoline clothing okay it stinks in here
yeah bet it does where it's collapsed in
so actually I'm like it's more sponsored
actually like dick some things they
change things they must spend some time
between the final station when it came
out and this one because I'm guessing
those honey use your feedback you know
if they didn't and they just realized
that once I just like fix it before the
game was released they like stuff about
it I'm waiting I'm gonna go yeah a
hard-ass that BAE sure I put on
deodorant today Anna I haven't done that
yet
why heal him thank you
social abilities pick one that's a go
zero and I feel like talking item one
see if we can fly through this game
doing like two sessions actually not
only like half an hour
hello Sergey access to computer oh I go
real over same old stuff same out starry
anything right here and up food so you
have to get all three items or can I
just get guys letting it to hop
hmm a news it's very confusing
no thank you I'm just trying to get by
here you know just trying to get by you
know
so this is actually Bunker you can tell
what the noise what that has a fat
frickin heart I think that you can keep
a bite off like a stray fumble not where
you run backward contact I like that I
just got out of shelter
I think is this specimens there like
studying specimens only that was money
okay I guess they had a little more
instruments like that where's my ice all
right hey boss
this guy's sucks crafting mmm
okay
when I died that over here can't
remember okay come on come on
I'd take my boss with me I hate that I
hate the walkers like the ones I curl
like that Oh give me a nasty one a fight
- what's going on over here and take
Sanne stuff cut that water I love that
swea water what is that a brain
electrum no thank you no thank you at
all okay with the launcher it's gonna be
too nice it's not me doing that today
you know
oh yes may chap Aneesa ow ow ow
oh you like Jenna you know I turn that
out I can't see what's in here can latch
to the pier Oh quick shift night
okay nothing round nothing rail we're at
that sweet gasoline I looked at a hit
come back that is like the best thing so
tired of Shaving unless I get in class
Shea's hats let's get two little in here
still cuz it's like force you back the
other way
how's it locked thick what what is he
doing oh you're trying to get shelter
that's why it's locked
yeah well cut down on air time that gal
yeah yeah so these are the shelter
errors I guess you lucked out didn't
make it down because car was too nice
you know this car wasn't fast enough
actually it's his boss so I'm going to
save him
it is so hot yeah my my eyes just like
melted incoming definitely melt that
gave me a nice power King yeah I got it
baby
can he throw cheese's he can hate those
things
I get coins ooh food not important you
know an important things are and it's
not that okay you love all those you can
go left right and so you should just
dorm right because because the train
comes to the left tunnel be ready
I am gues alene I got it naughty some
water and I can get the Attic out of
here
well when I went here money anak money
sex am
yeah they are get weird cool you can
interact with environment now my house
people are though okay now thank not a
day over there
so it took one person I guess
and net eggs
oh that was a horrible idea
yes it been animal well why wouldn't he
was such a waste
she says what am i doing I'm really
wasting everything in Epistle Emma you
should not agree that medkit she says
what the heck was that they're like
people break their window that's crazy
though Twitter I gotta fight people now
oh can I only kill their heads it's
interesting at least the combat is much
better in this game um last ones really
simplistic okay I should need some water
that's not thank you I'm walking this
one not Jesus hello I heard there's some
water here skip that for now
[Music]
mmm at the water like that like that how
I hate that he keeps doing that here's
the water see what else I can craft with
so it takes him for this car
scraps oh I got a med kit right oh can I
need to go and there I can't Jesus
leaving that the hell alone yeah that's
just not made for that what the heck the
heck kind I think I was asked how beyond
that carpal tunnel man you really get
optimizes for the controller what's on
here anything anything on you okay okay
now thank you oh my god are you serious
brah
oh my god oh my god Dorothy why am i
dying Samaj and I'm I'm sorry yes
stupid sucker see that see you later
there okay there's a medkit of a nice I
want to get that real quick and then
let's get the hell out of here
Tech last one was a medkit is it like
random and it's random I guess and I us
blow this giant okay there's two types
of people in the world people that like
to lollygag and people that like to get
down to business and make the money and
I'm one of those once I can't get down
to business and make the money yeah bro
you're gonna crap in something I don't
pick up people that are bleeding it's
just ten si from me
so the house setting up bata is right
oh my god I was here before get me out
of here no thank you
hey hey that guy's like yeah
yeah when I'm you know and I'm messy
yeah how you gonna mess me out huh
then I got some pills I remember this
place because I remember this diner
unless that's just like calm diner
oh my god hi
okay we're back